SAL: I'm here with Jessica.
What do you do here, Jessica?
JESSICA: Great question, Sal.
My title here is
the chief of staff,
but I like to think of it as
a catch-all for any position
that we haven't hired
full-time for, I pick up.
So it's a lot on the business
strategy and operations
side of the house
and covers everything
from recruiting and prepping
our documentation for our board
meetings to going to
Costco and picking up
the toilet paper if we need it.
SAL: When necessary.
JESSICA: When necessary.
SAL: From very high level
tasks to somewhat low level--
but sometimes has to get done.
And how did you end up here?
Where did you start your career?
What did you think you're
going to end up being?
JESSICA: I am a
native of California,
so I went through the UC
system, went to UC San Diego,
and started studying
electrical engineering.
SAL: And you went on some
type of super scholarship.
JESSICA: I was a Jacobs
scholar while I was there.
It is a full merit scholarship.
SAL: Named for Irwin Jacobs.
JESSICA: Yes.
Dr. Irwin Jacobs and his wife,
Joan, very generous supporters
of UC San Diego and had
started the scholarship program
in hopes of attracting talent on
the caliber of the Ivy Leagues.
He had been at MIT
before that and had
wanted to create that
culture [INAUDIBLE].
SAL: And this was a full ride.
JESSICA: It was a full ride.
SAL: And how many students
got this at UCSD every year?
JESSICA: So I was
the inaugural class,
and we were a class of 10.
SAL: A class of 10.
JESSICA: A class of 10.
SAL: Probably not
too easy to get.
JESSICA: I figure I was
just really, really lucky.
My parents were very happy, too.
SAL: And a lot less.
They could go buy
a car or something.
JESSICA: They were able to
retire a little earlier.
SAL: Retire a
little bit earlier.
And so you majored in
electrical engineering,
and so you thought
you were going
to be an electrical engineer?
JESSICA: I did.
So I did all of my internships
in electrical engineering,
had worked at a number
of defense companies,
worked at Qualcomm.
And then I ended up
going to Stanford
for a PhD in
electrical engineering.
And then my first
quarter, I actually
got sidetracked when
a friend took me
to a management consulting
info session that was actually
geared towards engineers.
And I had no idea
what this field was.
I'd never heard of it.
SAL: Few people do.
JESSICA: But they
had talked about,
you can have all this impact.
You get to work with amazing
companies and learn a lot
and travel the world
while you're at it.
And I just thought, what
could be a better education,
while getting paid a little
bit at the same time.
SAL: And staying
in nice hotels--
JESSICA: Exactly.
SAL: Nice dinners.
JESSICA: It's amazing how
quickly you become obsessed
with travel points.
SAL: And how long
did you do that for?
JESSICA: I did that for
three and a half years
following my master's,
so I went directly
from Stanford into McKinsey.
SAL: So you are now
in your early 20s?
JESSICA: Mid-20s.
SAL: Mid-20s, now.
And what kind of work-- how
was McKinsey what you expected,
or how was it different
than you expected?
And what kind of stuff
did you end up doing?
JESSICA: So I ended up
focusing on consultancy jargon
of operational and
organizational transformation,
which looks at the operational
piece goes into organizations--
oftentimes it's technology
organizations in my case--
and looking at how
people did things,
and thinking of ways they could
do it more effectively or more
efficiently.
So I worked with engineers,
data centers, executives,
and the like.
On the organizational side, it
was actually looking more at
how company culture
was, and how you
could make that thrive
in an organization
and think about
development for people.
SAL: Which sounds eerily similar
to some of what you do here.
JESSICA: Yes, very
eerily similar.
And then a third piece of
what I did at McKinsey, I
had this awesome stint in
their internal learning group--
so developing the
training of how
to make a consultant
a consultant
and looking at how to allow
people to learn how to problem
solve and become better
with client relationships
and interpersonal skills.
So I really loved the
learning piece of it.
SAL: And then, while you
were at McKinsey, that's
where you first met Shantanu
who is our president.
JESSICA: Yes, we worked on
several projects together.
SAL: And despite that, you
still wanted to work with him.
JESSICA: Despite that.
For some reason, rose
colored glasses [INAUDIBLE]
were really good
memories out of it.
Yeah, consulting
was interesting.
It was a lot of long
hours, a lot of travel.
People think it's
glamorous when you're
traveling to other places.
Oftentimes it was like,
typing up my PowerPoint
slides as I was on the
go and on my phone.
SAL: It's probably a
little bit of both.
It was a little bit glamorous.
JESSICA: The
traveling was amazing.
I don't think I ever would
have had an opportunity
to [INAUDIBLE] otherwise.
SAL: And you were interfacing
at a very high level
with a lot of these
organizations,
the senior executives.
JESSICA: Best
learning experience
I could have ever hope
for coming out of school.
SAL: Especially
at that age, to be
able to interface
with senior people
at some major
organizations, I could
imagine would be
very great learning.
JESSICA: Absolutely.
It was and incredible
training ground.
SAL: And then after
that-- what was it,
three and a half years-- and
then you decided to leave for--
JESSICA: Yeah, so after
three and a half years,
the lifestyle was tough.
I found whenever
I was at home, I
was just sleeping to make
up for the work week.
And so I decided to leave,
and I went to Yahoo!
Given my background
in transformations,
this was a company that was
in the midst of a huge one.
And I thought I could help.
So I went there-- also was
a great actual learning
ground for me.
I was able to interface
with everybody
from the engineers to marketing,
finance, legal, and just
learned about the
entire organization
and how things worked both on
the search side of the house
as well as on the advertising
side of the house.
SAL: And you worked with a
whole-- you ended up at Search.
You were--
JESSICA: I did end up in Search.
SAL: --a product manager there.
JESSICA: Yes.
So I ended up in Search as
a senior project manager
by the time I left.
SAL: And so that
sounded pretty good.
So how did you end up here?
JESSICA: Yeah.
SAL: Which now, in hindsight,
is the worst decision you ever
made.
JESSICA: Best decision ever.
You can pay me $5 after.
SAL: Yes, yes.
JESSICA: Just kidding.
SAL: I would have edited out
any negative remarks anyway.
JESSICA: I had kept in
touch with Shantanu.
And so he he had
told me, over time,
about how he was interfacing
with this guy named Sal who
was making these YouTube
videos, and I just
thought it was really cool.
I had checked out the site, seen
that we had all these practice
modules and some
analytics behind it,
and just thought what was
happening here was awesome.
So I offered up my
free time and said,
hey, I'd love to volunteer.
I started doing that.
And then right around
the time of the Ted talk,
things kind of got really
crazy for you guys.
And I had been helping
to try to find, actually,
a different role that you were
thinking of hiring at the time.
And then when things got crazy,
Shantanu said, hey actually,
you might actually
be a great fit.
SAL: Yeah, I think
we realized you
were doing more
in your free time
than we would have expected
from a full [INAUDIBLE].
It was like, maybe Jessica's
the right person for this.
And then you've come, and
that was 18 months ago.
But it was at an early stage.
I mean, how many
people were we then?
JESSICA: Yeah, when
I joined, I think I
was employee number
six, after Marsha.
She was really early on.
SAL: And now we're at what?
We're at--
JESSICA: We're now, I believe,
we're in our early 30's.
SAL: Early 30's.
JESSICA: Early 30's.
SAL: 31, 32 people.
And we have a bunch
of interns right now.
JESSICA: Yeah, a bunch
of awesome interns.
SAL: We're like five
times bigger than we were.
JESSICA: It's incredible
how much we've grown.
SAL: Yeah, it is incredible.
Wow.
And what's your takeaway?
What's the experience been
like, and where do you
think this is going to go?
JESSICA: Yeah, so my
experience has been phenomenal,
I think beyond what
I could have hoped.
SAL: I don't believe you.
I'm sure, but anyway.
Continue.
JESSICA: But it's
just been amazing.
I think the people
here are all just
so thoughtful and so
nice and just awesome.
Everyone's brilliant but
just humble about it.
And so I just feel
incredibly lucky to be
amongst this group of folks.
I think as we've
grown, we've been
able to [? main ?] the
quirky, fun culture of being
proactive and thinking epic
and shipping beats perfection.
Some of our values,
we've been really
great at keeping that going.
As we grow, it's interesting.
I think you once posed
the question around,
where would we be
500 years from now?
What would that ideal
picture be like?
And I think it'd be awesome
if Khan Academy still
exists in 500 years and that
we're still completely free
and that we have all
the content that anybody
could want to learn.
SAL: And plug directly into
their brain at that point.
JESSICA: Yes, by at that point,
hopefully it's just plug in,
and you're done.
But I think that
would be amazing,
if we could leave something
for future generations
to be able to use and
have a resource, that,
at this point in time, seemed
unthinkable that it would be
free and that anybody can access
that quality of education.
SAL: You're inspiring
me, Jessica.
JESSICA: The feeling
is mutual, Sal.